foreign
what is going on there citizens of the
reject Nation Greg here today well John
how are you I'm good however how are you
I'm doing well doing well we're getting
ready to shoot She-Hulk in a little bit
that video should be up already by the
time this video comes out but uh we
haven't done a movie news story in a
while and then uh I came across this one
it really really piqued my interest and
I wanted to talk about it because I just
thought this was so weird and strange so
in case you guys uh did not hear about
this there was a Black Adam TV spot that
came out called Legacy I believe and in
that trailer basically they were showing
footage of you know Justice League
members you know the batarang Superman
without his face
basically saying like before these
characters though the real Legacy
character the one before them all was
Black Adam that was the whole point of
the of the trailer but what happened
with the original upload the original
trailer they released there was like a a
second like a very small portion
honestly for me even when I saw this
Legacy spot it kind of flew over my head
I didn't really read much into it but it
was apparently a moment involving
Steppenwolf that was from the Justice
League version of of the Justice League
right and so Snyder fans got really
upset you don't say they got really
pissed off and now as as people who
would love to see restore the Snyder
verse actually take place you know we've
talked about it many many times there's
a part of me that finds this story just
like hilarious this is silly it's really
silly what happened basically there was
a huge backlash and a big part of the
backlash that that comes with it is
because of the debate of which Justice
League movie is the one that is
considered Canon now is it the Justice
League one or is it Zack Snyder's
Justice League and obviously one side of
that argument has exceptionally more
passion behind it but that fragment in
this spot that little fragment led to
such a backlash that I then saw Dwayne
Johnson tweet out corrected
so they removed that spot replaced it
with some other piece of battle footage
as to not anger the Snyder fans anymore
and of course it has led to many a
discussion now of okay wait a minute
does removing that mean that the Dwayne
Johnson is indeed fighting for keeping
Zack Snyder's Justice League actually
Canon he said corrected so if he's
saying corrected that must mean the
correct version would be Zack Snyder's
Justice League is the one and I consider
that one Canon personally and I've heard
rumors maybe this is actually
confirmative heard rumors Andy muschetti
considers Zack Snyder's Justice League
the one that's considered Canon for The
Flash movie I just think it's so funny
the amount of
and outraged and how much control they
can have in panicking Warner Brothers
and maybe Dwayne Johnson I bet stepped
in himself was like we gotta change this
guy we gotta take we can't Tire these
people off man well and that too and to
replace it with Black Adam footage and
not any Justice League footage
whatsoever so to me I'm like is this
corrected in terms of we've decided upon
the Zack Snyder universe or is this
corrected in terms of we are not having
this conversation right now yeah because
I'm under the impression that like they
had footage of you know Justice League
members but I don't think the movie
itself is going to use any of that
footage I believe that was solely for
marketing purposes and there's obviously
ways you can be vague enough about
Justice League experiences if
acknowledged in this film where it could
be either or you know you say
Steppenwolf and that could be either one
of those movies yeah absolutely it
doesn't really matter a lot of people
are I think already into this I just
think it's kind of crazy and a little
bit ridiculous obviously there people
who are on one side of the camp who are
like no it's not ridiculous Dwayne
Johnson had it corrected but we use his
duty to us yeah he owes this to us
you're destroying us I don't know I am
under the impression that Warner
Brothers is fighting headstrong I mean I
know they're under new leadership now to
distance themselves as much from the
Snyder verse fans as possible because
there's always stories coming out for
the longest time now that know they want
to actually make a cannon they want to
actually bring it back in some way and
Dwayne Johnson's the one who's fighting
for it but Zack Snyder has said he's
never actually had any talks with anyone
that implies that that is indeed what
they want to do nor is he actually even
really talked with Dwayne Johnson about
it you know I think it's something that
people are just kind of reading too much
into but I do find it insane and uh a
little bit outlandish that it's gotten
to this point well yeah because all this
ad is trying to do is is to probably
take the people who don't know Black
Adam as well and go he's in the same
universe as these people and like now
you have this whole distracting debate
about something that WB yes seems like
they would rather not have to talk about
at all and it seems like moving forward
into Black Adam if they did boldly
acknowledge the Snyder cut as the cannon
I think that would be super cool but I
very much expect them to vaguely
acknowledge any Justice League oriented
details so as not to make a direct
Choice with that movie and then eclipse
the movie's impact by making it again
about the Snyder verse you know yeah
because they're not trying to erase the
past and maybe the flash will try to
attempt it in some way because I don't
get the impression they're erasing the
past like even the Shazam trailer
featured footage from Justice League as
well so it's something that obviously
they're not going to try to erase
justice league history and even Ezra
Miller themselves had to come out and be
like no there's you can't erase it you
just can't but should we really allow
this much power hey man color corrected
the other Black Adam trailer all for the
fans they took out the Justice League
all for the fans Dwayne Johnson's your
direct man because that's the other side
of this argument that I hear talked
about a lot is about how much Dwayne
Johnson respects fans and listens to the
fans so much to the point that he will
go in and want to make these kinds of
changes to appease fans that he's he's
that connected but I I can't help but
have the skepticism of this kind of
response this kind of quick reaction to
things can that be damaging in the long
run especially when the Warner Brothers
is apparently setting out to establish a
type of plan when they're talking about
creating a plan wanting to mirrorify you
again that conversation being brought up
again what happens when there's a
backlash are they gonna react to that
are they just gonna always be on the
line to like oh people don't like this
change it now because I read nothing
into the meaning of the marketing behind
it because it was just an ed TV spot ad
again acknowledging Legacy into into a
promote Black Adam specifically not
really about Black Adam with the Justice
League I mean yeah you do see the Ben
Affleck batarang and the bad symbol you
do see the Henry Cavill suit so one can
read that much into it but at the same
time like I don't think you really need
to read that much into it I don't think
you need to get that upset over it to
the point where we need to make a change
here yeah you know like just to go hey
it's gonna fit in the same DVD box set
as all this other stuff that's all that
was that was meant to do yeah so I don't
know I just thought this piece of news
was a little bit hilarious I'm not like
pissed off about it or anything like
that it's just funny to me that it's
this is again an example of you know
Warner Brothers and Company being so
reactionary and if this is happening
right now I'm like you're talking about
sticking to a plan and wanting to create
one like what happens when people get
upset Dwayne Johnson and the fans are
the Kevin feige now because the purpose
of what's happening right now is the
Snyder fans the the ones who will never
be able to let go of the Snyder verse
not ever being restored they're always
going to complain they're always going
to be upset anytime they see or hear a
piece of Justice League mentioned even
in passing they will be set off and so
with this new plan if it involves no
Snyder verse people will be upset
regardless and are you gonna change your
plan according that well that's not
really Kevin feige of you if that's the
point is Kevin if I give you to pay
attention and then we'll apply this on
the next go around yeah not immediately
as we're in the middle of a current plan
like this just screamed the
directionless again to me and in a very
humorous way so get it together zass
love I don't know I imagine it was
Dwayne Johnson himself who had to go in
there yeah like we have to we have to
remove this because this isn't right but
hey if it actually is something that
deals more with Dwayne Johnson wanted
that removed because he does believe
that we should bring back the sign
reverse then all right cool this is an
important chapter in marketing history
apparently but what do you all think did
you think this was a necessary change do
you think it's just getting out of hand
leave your thoughts down below do you
think it's been out of hand for a while
probably do leave your thoughts down
below subscribe click that Bell and uh
hey we'll catch you all soon
[Music]